what is happening there citizens of the
reject Nation we are going to watch
today this horror movie trailer for The
Grinch called the main one John how are
you I'm feeling dastardly how are you g
I'm feeling good I feel like if if
there's a character from Christmas
classics Grinch lends itself to being a
horror movie we've had enough spooky
Santas let's do a grinch let's do a
grinch now after the Winnie the Pooh one
we're getting grinched or there's a
Bambi one I watched the 3C films I gave
up to date with the news
fairy tale guys leave a like that would
be very much appreciated let's get to it
remember that story about Cindy you know
who so oh God she knew what to do why
Santa Claus why but what have I said
that's not how it went down let's hear
it
oh my God
[Music]
oh Jesus
poor girl her mother was killed in mind
snap
did you ever find the Christmas killer
never got a reliable description of the
man
[Laughter]
this killer is back this town cannot go
through another Christmas killer thing
not again
that lives just north of the bill does
not what is it
me
I mean
yes yes
time to roast this Beast a roast beast
[Music]
Candy Cane shotgun this looks like a Rob
Zombie movie yeah yeah a little bit
enough zombie movie with almost no
budget
you know that's that's more along the
lines what I was hoping that Winnie the
Pooh horror movie would feel like I mean
it says right there it's a parody like
this is a horror movie comedy and
they're not trying to be serious one bit
about it like it's a silly concept and
weirdly I'm like there's one you could
kind of do something semi-serious on
here it could be because the Grinch is
is the evil Santa he's breaking he's not
Krampus but you know it breaks into
people's homes it ruins Christmas for
you and he's a monster he's a monster
he's a grinch there is that Verge you
could do it but I'm glad they're doing
something that feels like Christmas Camp
horror makeup on him looks really fun I
like the idea of they may want to take
him down is is hearkening to like
slasher final girl kind of movies as
well it has this Christmas spirit about
it like this is the kind of Christmas
horror movie I would be down to watch
because of the fact that it is like
silly and goofy it doesn't look like it
would ruin Christmas for me but instead
have fun with Christmas as the backdrop
for it so yeah I was I actually I
actually really like
yeah it has a really low budget buy
because especially hear it in the sound
design whatever who cares it's a
Christmas horror movie part of uh the
charm is is low budget like movies in
this budget bracket are for hypothetical
you know things like this that you would
never get on a larger scale and is that
the idea that the little that Cindy Lou
grew up and is now gonna take him on or
is that a different badass lady that we
see at the end with the candy cane
shotgun I mean it looked like the Grinch
maybe they just don't want to show it in
the trailer because it'd be too much but
it looked like the Grinch killed her mom
and said yeah she probably grew up I
don't know maybe one IMDb search away
from uh discovering what was going on
but then while I pull it up John what'd
you think yeah yeah I mean that
definitely got me intrigued it's it's
funny to see this this trend pop off now
of yeah anything and everything we can
get our hands on we're gonna do like the
schlockiest horror movie possible uh but
yeah I mean I feel similarly it's how
you did this doesn't look necessarily
like it's gonna be so icky and so lurid
that it wouldn't be fun to watch during
Christmas time and yeah clearly their
budget went towards realizing Mount
Crumpet I'm sure that's CGI cost them a
little bit and then the makeup and yeah
just seeing like I wanted more like it
made me I think in a good way want to
actually see what the movie is so you
can really get those makeup money shots
and I think it's probably smart that
they saved a lot of them for this they
only show them in brief flashes I mean
yeah it looks like a straight to video
low low low but this looks lower budget
to me than the Winnie the Pooh one did
but at the same time you know let's all
roll the dice why not yeah I would love
to make one of these someday and I mean
you know you got tons and tons of little
lines and references pulled directly
from the story I wonder they probably
can't use the word Grinch right so he's
probably just going to be called the
mean one the whole time but you know
they still have roast this Beast not be
public domain by this point that's a
good question I don't know Dr Seuss yeah
I mean and they are pitching it they are
headlining it as parody yeah yeah which
I mean that saves you know this the
parts of the law there with parody save
you from certain elements of copyright
infringement you know his definitely
looks like a Grinch story gone wrong you
know Newville having it be this like
just this regular town I guess like I
wonder if they'll work in who's at all
or if it'll just be yeah there's a town
of people and a grinch lives above it I
just love that there's this town of
people because apparently they're doing
kind of like a Michael Myers thing it
seems like with the Grinch yes where he
committed a crime many decades ago and
now he's back to terrorize the town
right yeah so I feel like there there is
something that I hope they lean in on of
creating like a small town lore Vibe I
like the idea of it's like it's a real
Christmas spirit town that loves it but
they do have this one demon that this
shadowy past that links them you know
instead of the Beloved Christmas special
it's the cautionary tale they tell each
year and you know maybe the kids don't
take it too serious but they will yeah
they will when he really shows back up
for reels I don't know I hope this is
actually a bloody good time but we'll
see guys what did you think about this
trailer for the main one David Howard
Thornton plays the green meanie oh is
that the guy from terrifier too oh is it
is it is he art the clown I think so oh
my dude this guy's just cleaning up then
yeah the terrifier too garbly hey man
that that bumps it up right there maybe
there's a shot I've been scared to watch
terrifier too oh why because I hear it's
extremely cold I love it it's gonna be
your favorite movie of the year reaction
that won't be problematic whatso no not
at all all right guys we'll leave your
thoughts down below be sure to subscribe
leave a like click that Bell let's end
this with a
Kevin smart Kevin you have been a patron
of ours for 21 months you were going on
almost two years I want to say that with
Thanksgiving just having passed we are
grateful for you for having been part of
our page for so long every Kevin I've
ever known in my life is a really kind
individual I can't think of a of a bad
Kevin that I've met not one k for kind
well there's that Spacey guy but other
than that one Spacey guy I didn't
personally know him all the other
Kevin's I've met are are amazing guys
and looking at your profile pic you look
like a smart intelligent individual you
also look kind of intimidating is this
really you oh dude bench press kind of
guy would not mess with yeah that is
actually an intimidating looking fellas
got the right curriculum like a military
guy dude you should take on the Grinch
if he was to come down and wreak havoc
on your town you could take him out also
with the sunset you have it looks like
you're probably practicing uh with Mr
Miyagi on the beach yes
do that crane kick well buddy uh thank
you so much for being Harvard page for
so long and supporting this for two
years now it's wild to have people like
you who find some type of value in US
more value than we find in ourselves so
thank you buddy
[Music]